a hit like a a bachelorette okay yeah
uh so yeah we're on a bachelorette and
she said she heard her boss
a bell went off on his phone she was
like I've heard that sound before
where's that from
she'd heard it on Tick Tock it's from
fans turns out him and his wife have DSM
only fans they're married with kids do
you think that's an optimal environment
for kids to grow up in with um basically
anyone can pay ten dollars and see their
parents having sex
if you went to my school your mum's
breast is going around all demanding
facts you know your mama's best maybe
not optimal but reality now
what do you what effect do you think
that will have do you think it's just
gonna become the norm do you think I
hope I think I hope not all my mates
bashing over my mom's breasts like no
what if they did it anyway without a
picture
because at the end of the day it's it's
selfish because you're putting you above
your kid you're putting like wanting
Quick Cash because that's another way
women are bailed out right if a man
doesn't have a job he's just homeless
if a woman doesn't want to work she can
go on only fans and make six figures
yeah and so it's it's
you can't really feel bad for those
girls either and say oh you're forced to
be sexualized because yeah no it's good
good because but a lot of a lot of those
girls will say that and then coming
after Mia Khalifa right and then come
back and and what's the other girl the
Jake Paul's
friends girlfriend a lot of Rhodes Lana
Rhodes came back and then says oh I
regret it later but it's like that you
got all the benefits and so they just
want quick cash and they're willing to
put their kids and their family's
reputation in the name of it
and yeah I don't think that's ideal for
kids I'm not saying women can't be
sexual at all but I just think in a
relationship it's going to be better if
you do it in the context with your
husband like she could have she could
have went to since she is a Dancer she
could have went to a dance class
choreography and there would have been
twerking in the choreography personally
I would but think that's okay because
it's within the context of a
choreographed dance it's not just
Beyonce random it's not just out at the
gas station just look like you just
pulled some girls and was like Hey I'm
Sierra come twerk real quick so it's not
literally the video she's just working
on the car there's no like this is a
build up to an album drop it's just just
no nothing I feel maybe it's a build up
to an album drunk but it's made to look
like it's not been given a lot of
benefits
does Beyonce need to twerk to build it
for an album drop no Beyonce just like
so why do you think she did it what do
you think because women women need
attention
I think she I think she misses being in
the spotlight I think she misses being
the center of attention because she's
really attractive and so in her 20s like
she was sexy yeah she was the it girl
and so I think you know in her mid-30s
it's like time's running out and so
that's why I always see these girls
doing these like nude photo shoots like
Hillary didn't Hillary Duff just do one
too
it's like right at that that party's
about to end and they're like real quick
let me show the world my body let me
and I could see I'm not saying she did
it because of that I can see Sierra
doing it to be like yeah I still got it
that girl that was in the ride music
video Yeah that's the same girl that's
doing it right now I still got the body
after three kids I still got it insecure
you're saying possibly is that like do
you have to feel unsecure okay put your
mic so why do you have to be insecurable
like when you're doing these things why
does it have to be insecurity I honestly
don't think it's insecurity like because
I think oftentimes that's a cop-out
women use and say I'm just insecure and
like that that's why I'm doing it no no
offense but like but like to me I just
think she wants attention I think like
girls like that are used to having a ton
of attention like how long has Sierra
been beautiful she doesn't know what
it's like to not be beautiful yeah
because she still is it's for now like a
long time yet no not really I mean guys
at some point at some I don't know we're
not really checking for Sierra though
yeah we're not yeah is there like there
was a time where Halle Berry was the
most beautiful woman in the world not
saying that she's ugly now but you don't
hear people she was relevant then she's
not relevant though yeah yeah difference
yeah so beautiful not relevant it's just
at some point like men aren't lining up
to date 50 year olds so at some point
the party ends it's some some women are
just hot enough they make it to 40 and
they're still hot yeah but that's the
exception it's not the rule and Sierra
knows her party is ending soon and life
is going to be very different because
she doesn't know what it's like to not
be beautiful so she wants to maintain it
basically yeah I just I think she's
getting all the attention she can
because time's running that's my my take
is that she's getting all the time she
can because like honestly girls that are
born like nines and tens part of me
feels bad for them because they don't
they don't know what it's like to not
have that attention and their whole life
that's been who they are is stunning
like they come into a room they're used
to everybody staring at them and so when
it runs out they don't they don't have
anything left she's 36. that's why
people idolize um the girl that used to
be ugly that glowed up because
she she knew what it was like when she
was ugly for the door to hit you in the
face because man went holding the door
open her personality is good yeah
[Music]
applied for the throat the blow up what
did you say I said appla for the glow up
girls
that's the thing they're always the
funniest too
you're a good shot if you've been cute
you've always like you were never ugly
come on come on I had mine were you ever
fat no I've always been an athletic
built
like 50 of women
so I'm gonna wear a bag on my face
you could why do you think guys would
have do like sex dolls yeah yeah they
don't really yeah if you guys wow that's
true and why do you think they say
butterface I don't care like it's dark
anyways we ain't gotta see you face man
that is true this is crazy they sweat 50
of the time on dating apps
yeah I believe that like some of my
friends have Tinder plus and they're
just like tenderness
okay I'm gonna Read Super Chat
um I saw one from sentience I saw him
roast me I know I know hold on okay um
zacion 12. I'm quite sure twerk shirt
twerking is just a stripper move and a
common one at that so I'm wondering if
strippers are becoming more public than
private oh that's true yeah
um 90 free Tope blue dress
um forgive your mom and return to your
dad oh
what we're going through thanks you
don't know he
but actually it's not just this
I've like seen this comment from it copy
paste like you said that to me before
I'm like I'm good I'm like I'm like I
like my back okay sentience um Blondie
you're missing the point like you're
missing